on se rend compte qu'en fait sous la
pelouse de Chantilly existe la pierre
qu'on utilise encore à l'époque qui est
la pierre de Saint-Maximin des pierres à
100 m de la porte des grandes écuries
une source naturelle de pierre mais
gigantesque 2 hectar et demi de pierre à
tailler dans le brut pour un bâtiment
tel les grandes écuries enfin je veux
dire c'est formidable aussi incroyable
que cela puisse paraître sous les
grandes écuries se cache un labyrinthe
aussi grand que trois terrains de
football à l'époque ce n pas moins de
50000 blocs de pierre qui vont être
extraits par ces grands trous creusés
dans la roche ces cheminées elles ont
deux fonctions la première les flux
d'air et puis la deuxième c'est aussi
l'extraction des pierres puisque on y
mettait des pièces de bois des charpente
et avec un système de pouli on remontait
les pierres à la surface c'est à la fois
un gain de temps et un gain d'argent
parce que dans un budget de construction
d'un bâtiment comme celui des grandes
écuries la part de l'achat de la pierre
mais aussi de son acheminement est
considérable ce n'est pas le seul
avantage dont les bâtisseurs vont
bénéficier et notamment lors de la
construction de la pièce maîtresse des
écuries le dô a des dimensions
exceptionnelles pour un dô d'écurie il
fait 28 m de haut à l'intérieur sur 20 m
de large c'est un chef-dœuvre de la
taille de pierre mais les constructeurs
français sont très forts sont très
habiles ils maîtrisent la technologie
un savoir-faire indéniable mais qui va
nécessiter certains ajustements en
raison de la taille XXL du dô c'est ce
que nous explique Jean-Michel Bouchard
compagnon tailleur de pierre et Meilleur
Ouvrier de France quand on fait un dome
à 28 m sur une dimension comme ça il
faut contrecarrer les poussées de ces
pierres qu'on met on met plusieurs
tonnes de pierres on les clave on taille
tous les cailloux à une certaine forme
pour que les poussées verticales soit
repoussé en horizontale qu'elle parte en
oblique et qu'à la fin elle redescende
dans les murs de chaque côté 5 m
d'épaisseur pour contrebalancer
justement la la poussée de ces la
promesse architecturale en quelque sorte
làdedans c'est qu'on se rend absolument
pas compte on a des murs qui sont plus
épais que dans n'importe quel château
médiéval pour s'assurer que le dô ne
s'écroule pas les ouvriers vont
également ajouter un autre matériau le
métal les constructeurs avaient la
prudence en fait d'introduire des
éléments métallqu
qui peut être à l'assemblage entre les
pierres pour renforcer la tenue
mécanique de l'ensemble des prouesses
architecturales d'autant plus
exceptionnel qu'elles sont réalisé dans
des conditions de travail épouvantables
on sait par exemple que le prince de
Condé paye un chirurgien sur place pour
s'occuper des ouvriers blessés et on a
également des témoignages sur des
accidents de chantier par exemple des
échafaudages qui s'effondrent alors que
les ouvriers sont dessus et donc
évidemment plusieurs d'entre eux sont
blessés mais il y a pire les ouvriers
doivent faire face à une autre menace
pour le moins inattendu Nicole Garnier
est la conservatrice en chef du Domaine
de Chantilly lors de travaux de
rénovation en 2008 elle et ses équipes
ont fait une macabre découverte et on a
trouvé ce crân humain donc qui a été
transmis à la gendarmerie qui a fait les
analyses nécessair visiblement il s'agit
d'un homicide puisqu'il y a une trace de
balle donc qui ressort de l'autre côté
l'analyse au carbon 14 qui était faite
par les gendarmes a indiqué que ce cet
homme ou cette femme on ignore le sexe a
été tuée entre 1650 et
1950 d'après certaines archives ce crâne
pourrait être celui de l'un des ouvriers
du chantier des grandes écuries une des
hypothèses c'est effectivement le compte
de charolet donc qui était le
gestionnaire du domaine de Chantilly et
dont on sait qu'il a tué certains des
ouvriers qui travaillaient sur cette TER
il utilisait les ouvriers de toiture
pour s'entraîner au tir en tout cas ça
fait partie des nombreuses légendes de
chantillly et notamment des légendes
noires de chantillly